hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay I'm
going back down to the depths here kinda
freaky I don't know if that monster is
gonna be gone or if it's still there
somewhere probably still there hope yeah
damn it
ah you gotta be joking me what Oh bull
honkey
all right let's go fine it was back in
this way I know door here goes
I'm hoping it's not because I was
running away from me before I didn't
really have anywhere to go
okay it's gone
okay goodbye hammer
ha so I use this hammer to break or I
need a chisel do I need cheese I have no
idea
come on open up open up all right you're
locked
oh this is the door to the other ah ah
okay I can dig it I can dig it
oh boy how much will I get I got plenty
and there's more in that container over
yonder and this is I really like this
mod and how it attempts to make a unique
level design because this is something I
never would have thought to make it's
really cool up now huh whale call
well
thought I saw a shape of somebody
[Music]
gigantic door can hammer on it huh huh
did not expect that to happen okay
though that's okay
whoo doggy some noise is going on here
what do we got
what's that nothing come on yeah
who's out there who wants a piece of me
oh come on I'm burning up the oil what
the hell are we doing down here come on
nothing down here I don't think there is
oh wait no these stairs are different ah
here we go
oh oh uh uh tinderboxes Yong Yong ha
there is a chiseled chipper which I can
use on the lock no wait no it said I had
to find the key for the lock did it I'm
confused now up epic bleep oh yeah so
awesome ain't gonna get me stupid whale
mating calls not gonna get me oh this is
just okay got ah come on give me
something real oh I see some laudanum
and some oil there's something down
there I need to get down there how do I
get down there do I go in the back way
Oh who's that who's there oh I'm running
up huh dot-dot-dot a review by Axman 13
hope somebody you know what I'm talking
about boxes no okay teacher
high chair what are you doing conspiring
with the enemy there no chair no chair
you are going to behave okay must spend
some back way to get to under the stairs
come on where do I go hello darn it
can I go oh oh oh oh super stealthy yunk
yonkers got him yes quite
I mean I you know not that much more oil
come here check you got some splainin to
do why was that guy sitting in you you
said I was the only one for you come on
let me around let me around the stoop
off Sonny you damn it alright whatever
whatever I don't care
I'm just going in the dark a chair will
light my way no anybody home okay I got
the chipper okay I could probably use it
on the other door if I could ever find a
way to get back up which is a bit more
complicated because I don't know where
the freaky Frank I'm going with all this
broken debris I get up there chair hang
on chair alright whoa
chair don't cop an attitude with me I
brought you into this world I can take
you back out huh yes
epic leap okay don't fall this time
perfect us duck the landing
oh come on these gigantic stairs I can't
climb up them oh it's bull honky there
must be a different way up then do that
it is just piss poor design whoever
built these stairs deserve to be loved
probably worth flogged
there's something down here mmm-hmm oh
no that was just the other ah yes I win
be well I live
run run Oh again once again well dot dot
dot that's cool and all but I'm gonna
not partake in any of that action
oh uh body Oh hop over uh poor guy
that's sad sad soul there's gotta be
some here gettin maybe oh no yes
possibly what anything behind there no
ok that was nothing big waste of time
oh I can go up here
hello any cool items for me to get no
it's the big pile of crap hello down
there don't break don't break don't
break don't break don't break don't put
epic 360 oh yeah so great wait huh can I
get down there because there are goodies
I thought I saw a break on the way back
when I'm running away from the monster
problem oh hello my boss James he's a
good leader capitalized James a lot of
free time and drinks a lot is two words
good times until one well he was going
strange like the workers comma lowercase
but I was spared no nightmares over
hallucinations should I tell my boss
uncapitalized boss or leave before it
happens to me what what happens wait I
thought your boss was having
hallucinations I don't know
kick chipper oh shut up I could have
done it I'm so strong dark
just a little bit like oh why is that
one so much brighter than that it's
unfair unfair why are why are all the
lights pulsing it's weird freaky freaky
weird see watch this that all
well now it's as bright Oh hide
somewhere I don't have close it close it
close it please huh oh good good oh oh
hello oh there he is there's mr. fatty
naked man fatty fatty no pants naked
Nicky Nicky who's there
I see you I see oh oh don't come okay
baby
ah
oh no no no no no bro dude man dog I'm
sorry I called you fat sorry I called
you naked but you are pretty damn naked
[Music]
okay I know
I know hello did you go away too scared
to fight me I would be too scared to
fight me too okay all right
chair well Thank You chair for giving me
that did you find that just for me
cinder boxes all right key up there hmm
oh girl oh my name capitalize name is
James I'm the boss of cellar East all my
workers are getting nightmares for some
reason some of the workers are dying in
their sleep a heart attack I think I
should leave good thought nasai at the
padlock key which means that I can move
forward in the story
hmm
mmm hey blah hire a look again it's a
seam in the wall
seam in the wall no seam in the wall get
your minds out of the gutters okay don't
break don't break don't break don't
break don't break don't break oh it
didn't break
Wow Oh what the hell what's up there oh
boy okay that monster was just looking
for its friend or was distraught over it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's going on
just this scoop yeah I can deal with
goop I can deal with goop goop is easy
to deal with I'm joy like a enough whoa
whoa whoa ah there's nothing I don't
know I don't know I don't know don't
care why is that red I don't care Oh
freaky deaky it was like I was being
pulled backwards or something it was
weird weird he weird weird weird who's
ever down there I know
all I know is that I got the padlock key
so I will be moving forward okay
all right it's really really really loud
torches here kind of stroke using
strange ding dong ding dong ding dang
close it behind me it's in here
[Music]
hello ah good easy off take these I need
that in our read this I request to all
workers to help me on fixing the roof oh
but they don't want to go back to the
cellar this place is beginning to
collapse
oh no joke no joke okay next level
loading screen do not take secret hole
take the way to the dungeon cells why
it's a living nightmare most of the
workers died there terrible things gone
wrong
take the hallway if it it's necessary it
can't possibly Oh grammar it's painful
all right that's actually all the time I
got for this episode thank you guys so
much for watching now as always Oh oil I
see it I see it I see it I see the oil
oh I see it it's up there I I totally
see it I can get up here come on
let me up I see the oil it's right there
all right okay that's it that's all the
time I got for this episode thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part bye-bye